Thanks all right so we were left we left
at this point where I want to I want to
look a bit inside these two boxes just
to give you a flavor of how behind the
same things are working and there is an
why I want to show you this is for the
people that are a bit interest in the
doing their application maybe they can
find some of this idea interesting and
also because then this will motivate us
to look at other design that people have
went through went okay so let's look
inside some of these boxes so I show you
transformation it was for instance the
where transformation where we filter out
in our example we filter out people that
are not less than the number we are
trying to compute the CDF for now here
we have different components so first up
as John was pointing out before mainly
this is based on code that has already
been built by other people in particular
here we have inside the same kind of
primitive the primitive where and that
is available in Linc this library for a
sql-like of programs so it's an
encapsulation of this kind of primitives
and what actually the pink
implementation does is to create a new
new pink wearable object that is this
object that has the data and the budget
and manage the tracking of the budget
and it creates a new one with a new data
mainly with the new table from which we
filter out the previous element so we
take the big table we filter out the
record that are not less than let's say
50 and we are returned
query with a new agent that is updated
now what is this a new agent new agent
is they were responsible for the privacy
budget and the idea is let me go here
the idea is that it is a new agent
compute for us the information that we
need to understand how much of the
privacy budget we need to consume in
particular this is a transformation and
we need to understand how what is the
influence of each individual on the
transform at the result in this case we
have a where operation which is a
filtering operation so we can assume
that if I have an individual in the
original data I will still a derive this
individual or this will be filter out so
the influence that each individual has
remained almost the same and so the the
upper bound we can give is one because
the influence is at most one now this
design I wanted to mention can in
principle supported also by other model
of differential privacy because here we
create a new agent that are somehow
responsible of pieces of pieces of the
entire data so this could support also
model like the local model of
differential privacy or intermediate
model I don't think people have look
into this yet but it's something that
maybe we as the people can look at in
this semester yes the local model I mean
are you talking about sort of play local
algorithms are you actually imagining
that like I have a query that sort of
you know the query gets dispatched to
like everyone's phone
so no I'm thinking I'm thinking more so
now I was thinking just about the
management of the budget and the local
model the one you suggest that the
dispatching of the query and so on is
what is behind the era but that we will
get to soon right after this yes when
you do parallel composition you split
into several agents that's exactly the
idea then you take the max for parallel
composition while for a sequential you
do this on
that's what I'm saying
I mean the way pink is set up is to work
on a global data set but in theory all
these structures that are built in can
be used also for other model when it was
proposed it was proposed for the central
model but I think adapting it to more
the local model would not be something
too difficult because the kind of design
is good intuition for why new agents
instead of just sharing the same agent I
can try to give an intuition but this of
course this was Frank design is not my
design so I I think the intuition is
just because by creating this chain of
agent we take care of the amount of
privacy noise we need to add and I will
show you in the next slide when we will
look at the aggregate so this
information here mainly is a kind of
multiplier that tell us the influence of
each individual and it does do through
different engines it's all tied to the
same underlying it so so now when I
operate on this new object the budget
for the original object is getting yeah
that's the that's the idea and that's
why these a new agent is built on the
previous agent this is a exactly the
idea so create a chain of agent now why
is with a new instead of an update I
don't know exactly
any other question now what I want to
make clear is that we are looking into
this box but they this is something that
the API designer does so if we want just
to use this language we don't need to
look into this okay but I think it is a
useful layer to look into that
particularly if you wanted to prove that
this satisfies differential privacy this
this is one of the pieces of code you
have to yes if you want to make sure
verify fully that this satisfied
differential privacy you need to look
into this box and verified that this is
and this I will come back to this
because this is one of the difficult
thing to do part of the trusted No okay
here is a I didn't want to go too much
in the detail but you can think as so
the way Frank used stability is the idea
that we start with the data set and we
generate a new data set and is how much
the influence of war occurred in the
original data set as in the transformer
data set we differentiate it from
sensitivity because sensitivity
interpreted more in that in the sense of
a numeric query so when we look at
aggregation there there is sensitivity
which is which is computer through
stability
let's look into that so this is how the
aggregation
looks like is the implementation of
noise account and again here we have the
implementation of count just in link
like before but now we add Laplace noise
and there is where we check if we have
enough budget so before adding noise and
returning the ends where we check if we
have enough budget if we don't we throw
an exception and we add Laplace noise
now I want to go even further in the box
because here there is another box this
agent alert so now I want to unfold the
Deezer to show you exactly how we check
for budget so this is the unfolded code
so here is where we compute the
sensitivity so we take the scale that we
have used before and we multiply it by
Epsilon assuming that we add Laplace
noise according to Epsilon so the
scaling is a multiplier for this
sensitivity and with these that we
compute the new epsilon then we check if
we have enough budget to other to
account for the new epsilon and then we
are the Laplace knows accordingly to
this and we decrement the budget okay
so it's what you would expect it's just
that this is baking in the API and we
don't have to if we use it we don't have
to look into this we don't have to do
this and manually
okay and again this is provided by the
API designer okay all right so back to
the big picture we saw an example with
this we we saw two example one using
parallel composition and one using
sequential composition now any question
about this okay so just a few other
words about pink so in the original
design it was supporting only
differential privacy the pure definition
but is a design that we can adapt to
other definition like are any
differential privacy CD peds at CDP and
so on clearly are the idea is of
focusing on programming so we want to
give a user the ability to program this
kind of application and that it has been
extended also with some other feature
that I didn't discuss here to address
graphs a graphs application or to
address a streaming algorithm I can give
you more information if you need now the
other language I mention is this era but
that was a quite old project it was from
a UT Austin when vitalism article was
there and the idea was to provide an
interface like pink but based on the
MapReduce paradigm asuras the idea that
John was saying it to dispatch the query
or at least the way he entered that John
question it was the idea of dispatching
the queries to smaller and smaller part
of the data and then aggregated by
reducing
again it focuses on programming the
management of the budget is a bit
different but the general idea is
similar now I'm not I didn't see
actually the code that the census is
using but as far as I know is a
combination of some differential privacy
there's a primitive and some Map Reduce
approach based on a spark I think so in
some sense I think this kind of approach
could be useful for other application is
a bit a pity that was discontinued and
nobody's working on this anymore but I
think is a good approach and I believe
it should be something we should
consider again so in the original in the
original design yes they made the main
question I think that is also related to
some to the use of sample and aggregate
and other approaches is that what
exactly we can do with the reducer so in
some sense is still focus on programming
but is more limited yes when we reduced
we need to aggregate and also the fact
that the user has to manage the budget
is sort of like a arguably that was the
thing that kink was trying hardest to
again to avoid yeah yeah exactly so
that's I think they were both quite
early paper and they were addressing to
different kind of problems so this issue
will come in the trash
so ins so we need to distinguish I think
a two kind of timing attack the eye
level timing attack like trying to build
baking a program that just lets say wait
five minutes if copies in the database
and otherwise it gives right weight
yarns were and this the first
implementation of pink was the
implementation of pink a is a subject to
this kind of attack I think people know
how to address them but they were never
address I think we know how to address
this kind of issue
we need a runtime that addressed them
but they were never address and and also
a wrap
any other question so in general it's
possible to build these systems that
give us do the surance against
cyberattacks like I think reasonable
assurance like yeah so for instance
people have look into building runtime
system where the order of microseconds
you don't have some chat side channel in
the sense that you need to make sure
that you put your your operations or
every operation takes the same time and
you cannot distinguish so in principle
is possible and there is a lot of
research in formal methods outside of
privacy trying to address this kind of
problem
it's a problem that all the security
application ever and there are some
countermeasure of course we are in if we
go there we are in the setting where I
found the contra measure then there is
another attack that come in and is
difficult to really say which side
Channel if they are completely addressed
okay so we have two languages that do
differential prior and that helped us
building application for differential
privacy why do I have a still time to
talk so why are M we done so let's try
first that we understand a bit of what
are the trade of here for pink and
rabbit and I go back to the picture I
presented you before and the place I put
pink as I said is difficult now to
realize but the idea is that is a quite
good usability is not super expressive
in a way that I want I will explain soon
and the granularity is quite low so you
should imagine that is quite against the
world okay so why why I put it there so
usability I think the burden on the
programmer is quite low in the sense
that as you as we saw before we can just
use this primitive which put really low
burden on the programmer because they
are very similar to the one we would use
it linker or in c-sharp
now the expressivity i put it a not too
far on the right because it's true that
we can a program with it but in some
sense we are a bit constrained by the
kind of building blocks that we have so
we cannot do to certain feeling with our
application so the algorithm that we
would like to do is quite constrain okay
many what we can do is a composition
composition and basic primitive and then
the granularity is because we have these
black boxes behind and we are relying on
them so we are not really proving
jung-hwan application correct but we are
just relying on some principle that we
hope will work well so what are some of
the issues so here I try to identify
some issues and try to connect them at
what people have done after this works
so one of them will be the next step so
now it will be more looking into the
boxes and try to understand what we can
do there now I want to focus a bit on
the fact that several aspects of the
enforcement depend really on the
particular implementation so we look at
inside the code and we are relying on
that code what happen if we get
something wrong so for instance here we
were computing the sensitivity I said
but what if we have some bug that gets
into this why why it is true that this
is the sensitivity how how can we
guarantee this what about if the
sensitivity is brown we are adding the
wrong amount of noise so we are not
differentially private also reasoning
about this can be subtle and pink
doesn't give us any formal calculus to
compute the sensitivity so how do do we
make sure that is the correct thing to
do another aspect that I mean that
people were a bit unsatisfied with pink
is that the privacy budget enforcement
is dynamic what do we mean by dynamic if
we go again into the box we had these
checking of the budget and if we don't
have enough budget we do
throw an exception now is this bad so I
don't think it is unnecessarily bed I
think is important to have some dynamic
or some kind of way that is dynamic to
track the budget but I think is
important also to realize the difference
between tracking the budget dynamically
because we are trying to do an
interactive kind of approaches or
interactive queries or a dynamic because
we do an analysis of our algorithm which
is dynamic so in most cases that the
algorithm be analyzed statically and
then we can still have a dynamic
consumption of the budget when we run
the algorithm so in some sense this is a
bit unsatisfactory because by relying
only on dynamic guarantees we don't give
information to the user about how you
can organize this privacy budget while
in theory we would like to have a kind
of planning that we can do where we can
say ok I have a query aid that cost me
some amount of some epsilon one I have a
query bid that cost me epsilon B and
then I can decide which one to run and
so on so these approaches are completely
dynamic and don't allow this kind of
so people have tried to address this too
and let me present one approach on which
I was also involved I didn't put on I
put a general citation because there are
many work in this direction it was
worker mainly done at UPenn by the group
of Benjamin peers I was there for a
couple of years and I keep collaborating
with them so this approach tried to
address these two issues that I just
mentioned so the first one was the
enforcement depend on particular
implementation and then the dynamic
privacy budget so and I do how did we do
this so first we build there our new
language on its semantics model based on
the idea of metric spaces and non
expansive function non expanding but
with the idea of having a model where we
can reaso really about sensitivity and
we can say this function this program
has this sensitivity and again it relies
a bit on the specification of the user
on some basic primitive but this
specification now is supported by a
mathematical model that guarantees that
is correct
the Tula that we ever doesn't do this
connection but in theory we could prove
that each of a basic building block as
the good sensitivity and the tool that
we have is implemented as a type checker
instead of as a dinamic
monitor because then we can do this
statically and again is similar to the
previous one because it doesn't require
reasoning about probabilities so what is
the idea here it's a this idea of having
a semantic model first from which to
start and this is not a new idea it was
already
in the original paper calibrating noise
to sensitivities just we made it more
formal and more available to the
programmer
formal Simmons yes
so the way I use it is formal semantics
which is exactly which mean that every
program as a mathematical interpretation
which is the model the semantic model so
sorry every program is interpreting a
semantic model which is in a
mathematical function describing what
the program compute so is in the same
way if you want that formal logic uses
semantics like when I have a formula I
have a model for it if I can interpret
this formula sorry when I have a formula
I can interpret it in some way another
domain that is maybe a functional domain
or maybe a truth value the truth value
base domain or a crypt a model domain
and we use in the same way
meaningful profits
questioning even make sense so being a
so the exact model we use is a model
based on function as I say the metric
spaces and on some a specific function
which is not expansive and now we can
reason about these in the usual
mathematical way so we can prove
properties about specific element in
this model they may be what is a bit
confusing for you is that how we connect
the property we prove in the model with
the program so mainly we transfer the
property from the program to the model
we we interpret the program in the model
we prove the property in the model and
we transfer it back to the program so
but okay but something in the real world
here is a program is not the isn't so is
something that is also we cannot so
formalize I'm not talking about data
analysis or I'm talking and starting
from a specific program so this specific
program is a piece of code that is a
clear interpretation so the
interpretation is the one that when I
run the program I will see the result so
we are not trying to interpret the
reality in the model we are trying to
interpret the specific program
okay so based on this idea we build this
language and the idea is that is similar
to what we saw for pink but the key idea
is not any more composition but is more
compositional analysis of the
sensitivity of program is a slight
change which give a different properties
and the key property that we want is
that we can formalize it so that we can
say when a primitive is good to add or
not and also in blur together at the
sensitivity and the stability concept
that we saw in pink because now we have
only sensitivity so on SOI
transformation on the data will be
sensitive in some sense okay so let's
see how we reemployment these in these
languages so that we I will try to give
you a feeling about this work so mainly
the implementation is exactly the same
as the non-private one so
we start from an implementation that is
exactly the same as the non private one
and then we try to estimate the
sensitivity at type-checking time of
this function and then we add noise and
we check that we are the noise in the
correct way so the kind of way they type
maybe some of you are not familiar with
that checker but let's say the way our
tool work is we take this kind of
program and we wonder how sensitivities
on the database how how much noise do we
need to add and to compute this mainly
the program the type checker sorry will
perform a program analysis trying to
infer this quantity and now it works so
as I said before we have some basic
primitives that have a sorry sensitivity
here I put where as a basic primitive we
can go inside where because in some
sense we have this semantics model that
support our reasoning and we can make
sure that now this is the right
sensitivity and we can do the same for
count and then the type checker combined
for us and say that the overall
sensitivity is one since we are mapping
it over the buckets so we have multiple
buckets now we need to think about this
compositionally and we need to provide
to the type checker a bit of information
because the type checker is not able to
directly detect diese so we need to
provide the length of the data to the
type checker because this is statically
statically determined and so now we can
compute the overall sensitivity by
solving Samarra currents equation that
tell us that is n now this is n in
our model because we have a generalized
sensitivity that work over all the data
structure included the data set and then
with this we can add the noise and again
the type checker propagate the
information - sorry - this and this
guarantee that we are an epsilon
differentially sensitive as I said every
program so this program is interpret in
a metric model based on a non expansive
function and in particular this is a
function and the sensitivity is the
property of the function okay so is
because we have a multiple argument
function and so I brought it write it in
this way to say that is the sensitivity
on the first argument so one of the key
point here is that now we need to
provide so like before we need to
provide some primitive that we use and
but also we need to provide a bit of a
notation like the length of the list why
we write n here is because so at static
time when we do our type checking we
don't ever available the length of the
list that we will apply this program to
so we need to generalize and introduce a
variable and that say represent the land
and then we can use this information in
the in the type checking
any question
I know some of this type checking is not
familiar to most of the audience but I
think the overall picture is that we can
statically ensure now that a particular
piece of code compute require write an
amount of privacy budget so we can
determine statically how much budget we
would need for this query and we could
do this also in other methods but in
this case we do with this sensitivity
tracking and this idea is a kind of
alternative with what we have seen with
Bing has been develop also to address
adaptivity because in this sense the way
I presented you seems very static but
then we can use the static checking
inside of a runtime environment where we
will discount what we use for each query
from the real budget at the right moment
any question
[Applause]
okay then let me try to put these so I
think maybe just this point you are just
making edging about adaptive so long
it's a movie no I'm having a little
trouble sort of visualizing like so I
write a program that's going to make
decisions about which epsilon to use at
various points in the middle but when I
write the program
it's like checked whether I could
possibly exceed the budget so you can
think about these in maybe in this sense
so here you can imagine that you want
implement some data analysis let's say K
different data analysis and now this
method tell you each one of them how
much it will cost in the sense of given
a parameter it will tell you how much it
will cost
now you can imagine of when to use them
you will have another program that we
use them and that point you need to
commit to a specific value of Epsilon
and you will discount this from the
general budget so in some sense this
epsilon here is a parameter it's not a
concrete Epsilon
so we are just analyzing how much
parametrically dysfunction consume like
when I write the program and compile it
like well I compile it and it'll say
like sorry I can't guarantee that you
stay in the budget or will it like run
and sometimes it runs and tells me that
I exceeded the budget and have to cut me
off
or will it like I say so once you
compile so it depends if you want to use
the interactive or non interactive mode
if you use the non interactive mode or
non adaptive mode then it will just say
you okay you can run your bunch of
queries or not because you have
accounted in the right way or not in the
interactive one instead it will have
mini-batches
and for
each one of that will tell you if you
can do these mini batches or not they
are not alive right whether whether the
batch of queries will satisfy the budget
no that is I mean any run it and then
find out that I don't know no no no no
no sorry you can determine before
running okay I get that it's like always
epsilon differentially private but like
I may start running the code and it may
tell me like sorry I could not answer
all the questions so the difference is
that this may be let me try is with pink
you run you are running the analysis and
you get this exception if you don't have
enough budget here you are saying I want
to plan this set of queries tell me if I
have enough budget or not so it's before
running you commit to all your use of
steps before you see the data so no not
it depends again so it was extended to
work adaptively based on the privacy
filter approach and there you can see
the data before committing
all right so let's see where do we put
this so I put it here meaning that I
think is a bit less usable than the
previous one because now it requires
some kind of a notation that we didn't
need for pink and a bit of reasoning
about sensitivity which is a kind of
expertise it is similarly expressive
because we can do more or less what we
can do in pink and the reason why I put
idea is to give a bit the direction of
grammar very bad idea I agree all right
so a bit closer to us in the sense that
now we are describing like your own work
is dominated by the previous so as I say
the bit less usable similar expressivity
and the granularity is a bit it has goes
a bit more in granular somehow in my
mind the expressivity from what I
understand the experts innovative I
repel is like way less than what is
expressible by pink yeah I think you're
right right in some sense also with pink
you can do only statistical query at the
moment because you have only aggregation
doesn't provide like an exponential
mechanism
no but it's the report noisy max version
right so that's like a mathematically
different so right you don't pay for the
number right right you couldn't do that
that's the point you couldn't do that in
iRobot yeah
you know you could implement like the
static version the offline version of
multiplicative waves in pink and you
cannot do that and I also I think the
reality is that pink was a working
project in the sense that in the
original pink and the code that is still
available online
there is no exponential mechanism in the
analysis I think they did for another
project they added the exponential
mechanism so it's not exactly clear I
think is the problem of research project
research software project it was a bit
an experiment okay all right so let me
look a bit at the other problem I think
another issue here is that these that we
saw are a kind of a general-purpose
approaches but they are missing
domain-specific tools and I think when
we want really to do some data analysis
maybe these are useful people are trying
to address this I think one of the word
that I like the most is the one by
people at UMass and other where they
really try to build the language that is
in principle like making sense but where
we have a more of a domain-specific
primitives for dealing with data so we
can do bigger debt analysis than what we
could do with the basic pink
Sarika me so when you say there's sort
of more domain-specific you're like
referring to the fact that there's all
these like I'm referring for instance to
the fact that it provide some proper
some construction like ambien vectorized
object trying to use a bit like a view
of the data that is more specifically so
I think the language permit only to do
linear queries at least in these
implementing this implementation so it
focuses really on linear queries and out
to do them well and scalable so but
again like it sounds like this you could
in principle have just built this on top
of it so in that sense it's like not a
right it's not clear that it's doing
something qualitatively like you could
think of it as purely syntactic sugar
right yes but I don't like this view
because then everything is syntactic
sugar no this is it
I mean there are things that in terms of
you're talking about expressivity right
in terms of sort of like the families of
algorithms that could possibly be
analyzed if there is like if there are
differences between these systems in
terms of what they can yeah yes so these
are these are I win I didn't put on my
picture but these are I would consider
it less expressive but we have again in
terms of what we can do in the way we
can do things in the usability and
usability taking into account on so
accuracy and efficiency
I think usability I mean like you know
there's lots of things that go into
whether like I can personally use the
language I sort of think of usability is
like you know how much work are you
asking the program
to do sort of on top of writing the code
I think maybe this is like you know if I
have to write some of these functions
myself like to you know do useful
transformations for useful
transformations for like implementing
some of these algorithms that's that's
like just sort of programming that's
just writing the code right like I can
either do it by hand that can use this
function but it's not sort of asking me
it's not harder to use in the sense that
like I'm not doing I'm not like having
to get say like additional understanding
of privacy or like additional route I'm
not having to say like supply in tags on
my code explaining to the type checker
like why this should be no but in some
senses so the usability is also you so
for me is like would you as a programmer
if you use pink are you able to arrive
to the same scalability and the same
kind of analysis you can do with a
software that has been designed to do
that in general I require you bigger
effort more people that like used pink
some of these functions and it would
have ended up having like this exact
instead of rate like you know people
like you please Python libraries right I
could write all that code myself at some
point it didn't exist yeah it doesn't
make the language more expressive it's
just like you know it's an ally
different thing yeah I didn't say it
sorry is there an interesting example
because you mentioned efficiency so I
mean again there's not I don't this is
not meant as a comment against ekdal Oh
in any way it's just like conceptually
what this is providing is you know
arguably a subset of what pink does plus
sort of a bunch of functions that are
provided in the I guess the language or
the framework that allow one to you know
that provide convenient pre-programmed
ways of doing very
right in contrast if I take a Python
library like numpy like that is not just
a bunch of a bunch of Python functions
it's like super optimized C code that it
together with like a Python skin that
allows me to call those functions right
so in terms of efficiency it's like it's
there's a huge difference between what I
can do with numpy and what I can do in
in native Python and raw like maybe not
in terms of privacy or functionality
quickly so I guess that you know that
seems like again like another thing that
one could imagine these could this could
have done but that's from what you're
saying that's not what what's here it's
not that these are like required like
new as John was saying like let's call
any additions to the trusted code base
it didn't didn't require more things
that have to be analyzed carefully for
privacy written I mean my understanding
Ryan is Erik and I also correct me if
I'm wrong but my understanding is that
these are trusted primitive data rod and
the key point is out to design these
primitives so I'm not claiming that this
is more expressive than pink I think we
all agree since this deal with linear
queries that is less expressive what it
allows is to do like it is a in some
sense optimized for this goal is like
the primitive that it provides are the
primitive that you would reasonably use
to do this to reach this goal and these
are not provided in pink you can try to
implement them in pink you can add them
to pink and in the end yes I think you
would get something similar but I think
the the main point is that when you add
the primitive you need to think about
the primitive that you are is a
programming language design these are
these primitives in the language or
they're just like functions that are
there that you can use you can like yeah
you know you could rewrite yourself
right like that seems like again there's
like a qualitative difference between
either things that are like in the let
built into the language or or again
things that require trusted like in
order to for example prove privacy you'd
have to actually inspect their code I
suppose rightly the difference between
that the where operator that paint
provides on the private database that
you showed us yeah there was a line in
there that where the there's like the
stability of that operation and that's
like an operation that you'd have to
like if you're gonna argue that this is
private you have to like argue about
that line of code yeah I think all of
these have that okay like this is where
for instance exact example you took so
in some sense I think is like maybe what
confuses you is how I'm interpreting
this as a pink a give us a general
picture of how to do the tracking of the
privacy budget now for me we should not
stop there but we should also think
about what kind of functionalities we
want our language to provide and I think
what this language does is to go through
what we would need to do linear queries
in a good way
okay okay it
so in some sense of what I'm trying to
say is that the generality is not always
the goal maybe by restricting you have
something that is less general but more
useful in another direction now the
other problem is for this kind of pink
architecture is that is difficult to
formalize people have tried to formalize
part of it now why do we want to
formalize again we want to make sure
that is correct
so I'm yet not sure completely that the
way pink is implemented is correct I'm
not sure it does all the privacy budget
accounting in the right way of course
again I think it's a research project
pink so of course there might be some
typos and so on I don't want to make
anybody accountable for that
it's just I'm saying when we want to
design software that is correct it would
be good that we can formalize it and
with pink is quite complex and people
have tried we will try to use some
formal methods to do this but is
difficult to do and the finally the
other for me main issue that pink has is
that it doesn't provide any support for
reasoning about privacy accuracy
trade-off and the some other group have
tried to address this for instance group
that was developed here provide a way to
give information also about the accuracy
of each analysis and also the project at
Arbor that Salil
has led focus very much on trying to
provide the information about the
accuracy of each analysis not only
guarantee that they are private and by
the way we will have a more about on
this different tool presented at the
next workshop so you can go back for it
alright so in the next lecture I will
give you a feeling of how to go inside
the black boxes and then I will try to
give you some pointer for the rest of
the semester another question
I think this is a good break for lunch
sir 115 in this room
there'll be a discussion on on GP and
its use in the census on that too also
in this room